hello somewhere around the time that
phones became these flat pieces of glass
that we keep in our pockets
they lost their somewhat natural curve
now I don't personally miss that bend in
phones but LG it certainly does I'm
Johanna Stern and this is the LG G flex
one of the first phones to have a curved
and flexible display and it's not just
curved for the sake of being curved LG
says that it's actually more comfortable
to hold to your face and reduces glare
when you're watching on it those seem
like enough reasons to want to check out
this phone LG says the design helps fit
your face and in your hand better and it
is actually a little bit more
comfortable to hold up to your ear or at
least as comfortable as holding a
six-inch screen to your face can be LG
also says it'll fit more comfortably in
your pocket I guess that's true if you
can actually fit this thing in your
pocket but similar to curved TVs that LG
and Samsung have been showing the
biggest benefit is that it makes the
viewing experience a tad more immersive
that could be a result of the very large
OLED screen it's very bright and has
great viewing angles LG also says the
screens band reduces glare especially
outside and that's somewhat true as you
can see compared to the galaxy s4 there
is slightly less reflection and true to
its name the Flex really does flex the
phone absorbs the impact when I do this
or this and I didn't even worry about
scuffing it when I stepped on it because
of its self-healing power no you don't
need to meditate with this thing but the
coating on the back actually feels
itself from small nicks and scratches
it's not meant to withstand deep
scratches say from a knife or scissors
something like that's not going to go
away
only lighter Nicks from your keys or
other objects in your bag will heal see
these smaller ones from a key lessened
over a couple of hours and then almost a
day or two later completely disappeared
that's pretty freakin cool
you also notice in the back that there
is a power button and then volume
buttons and that this button can
actually work as the camera button I
understand the idea your fing
is already near the back of the phone
but it's really hard to get used to at
least you don't have to always use that
button to turn on the phone instead you
can just tap on the screen and the only
thing it is handy for and I hate to
admit this publicly are selfies speaking
of the cameras the 13 megapixel rear
camera takes fine photos though they're
not as nice as the ones taken with the 8
megapixel camera on the iPhone 5s
software though is my major gripe with
the phone people aren't gonna want to
watch a YouTube tutorial about their
phones features and that's the only way
I figured out about this dual window
feature besides that the user interface
is often cluttered and distracting LG
has crammed a lot of technology into
this big screen phone and the curved
screen is actually nice looking and
something I'd consider if all factors
were equal but they're not especially
the software and have I mentioned this
thing is huge
instead I recommend the Moto X for the
iPhone 5s LG is certainly flexing its
muscles with the G flex but for $300 it
just falls flat yes yeah no I'll be
right there